okay i hope uh people are able to see
the screen
so in this session
uh we're gonna see the presentation of
these five papers in this specific order
and i'm gonna just have a few
introductory remarks on
why i excited that these players during
it
so on
these fall under this broad theme
of fine grain complexity
and
so finding complexity theory
traditionally deals with np completeness
of computational problems and this
notion of fine grained complexity sort
of gives this more refined
distinctions between exact runtime
needed to solve problems
and it was initially sort of
expressed for problems in p
where you had they had to rule out
quadratic algorithms and so on
but also it was used in np completeness
for taking np heart problems and
distinguishing problems where there are
non-trivial exponential time algorithms
versus problems where the brute force is
essentially the best possible thing
and of course it also had all these
connections to the randomization and
everything in traditional complexity
theory
so we have in this session we sort of
have an example of each one of these
things
we have examples of problems in p
we also have
np heart problems and we have
computational complexity standard
questions that we ask
in particular let's look at
the first paper which you'll see today
is for
showing that there are no better
approximation
or even exact exponential time
algorithms for lattice problems
this is a line of work that started i
think about seven years ago and now we
have some additional hardness and
hardness approximation results
for these bounded problems this shortest
vector problem and its variance
so we're going to be seeing about that
and
also as the advent of fine time
complexity happened the emphasis sort of
on
computational algorithms which are like
some better sub quadratic algorithms of
quadratic approximation algorithms
started to have a more punch because now
we had tools to prove hardness results
so here in this talk we're going to see
how for a natural generalization of edit
distance called tree edit distance we
have a truly sub quadratic
three approximation or three plus
epsilon approximation algorithm and this
truly interesting like
because now we have an emphasis we
always have a question of whether there
is a lower bond or is there an algorithm
so we're going to see in this case there
is an approximation algorithm
and of course
you can ask standard like in
computational complexity we have these
intimate links between proof systems and
so on so forth and so there are natural
questions in which have uh you know
which are conjectured not to have some
quadratic time or sub cubic time
algorithms so one can ask are there m a
protocols which are non-trivial for
these things and they have also been
recently shown to have connections with
hardness or approximation
and in this work they're going to give
very non-trivial uh ma protocols for
many important problems in finding
complexity
and then finally we're going to wrap
this all up with a couple of papers
related to
quantum computation and fingering
complexity uh where the main question is
uh
uh do how much does quantum speed up the
algorithms like you know if there are
certain problems like closest pair how
much does how much quantum speed up can
we gain can we prove upper bounds are
giving algorithms quantum algorithms can
we prove conditional lower bounds by
putting forth some conjectures and in
this in these two papers we look at
these things the first paper looks at
a quantum version of the three sum
problem and based on that conjecture is
going to prove many
interesting conditional lower bounds
quantum lower bounds the second paper
looks at
string problems and is going to give
non-trivial quantum algorithms for that
so i'm very excited that we have all
these uh you know thematically unified
fingering complexity papers in this
session
and now i leave it to the first
first paper i improved hardness of input
hardness of bdd and svp under cap scph
do we have a representative for the
first speaker
fantastic
heat tank
are you able to
share your screen
good question
let me see
[Music]
does he need to be the host
yeah i think you need to be the host let
me try to see if it's possible
hi
i guess i could now share my screen
okay great
you see it
yep
wait a minute
i will give you a call around the nine
minute mark if it's okay with you
sounds good
can i start now
yep you can start okay cool
thanks a lot for the introduction uh my
name is e and today i'm going to talk
about this improved hardness of bdd and
sap under gap and cth
this is a joint work with hud band and
chris picots
so bdd and sap are known as lattice
problems so i'll start with introducing
this notion of lattices
lattice is roughly speaking a regular
grid of points in space
and more formally a lattice of rank n is
a set of or integer linear combinations
of bases of size n
here for example we could see a lattice
that is generated by the bases b1 and b2
and all the black dots are the lattice
points
and we could also see that different
bases could actually generate the same
lattice
and the study of lattice is motivated by
the
so-called lattice-based cryptography
nowadays we are kind of approaching more
and more practical quantum computations
and there's a problem that attacker with
quantum computation can break
traditional cryptography
based on number theory
and one solution here is that because
people could use lettuce based
cryptography because people believe
uh lettuce problems are hard to solve
even with quantum
and currently the state-of-the-art
attacks on on the lattice days crypto
systems are based on solving the exact
or low approximation factor version of
lattice problems such as the svd problem
that i will introduce in a minute
and
then here comes another problem that
whether the attacker can solve these
problems in qddn or killing anova 10 or
to the root and time
actually has a huge impact on the
security of the crypto system
so our work tried to address this
problem by
showing the fine grained hardness
results for less problems
one
one problem studied in our work is the
sap problem and in scp important
geometric properties
that is
concerned is the
lambda one of the lattice l
here it the um it is defined as the
shortest lp norm of nonzero vectors
in the lattice
um taking our previous example we could
see that the red vector b2 minus b1 is
to show this nonzero lattice vector
so here its length is lambda 1 of the
example that is l
then the gamma approximate sdb problem
in lp norm is defined to be the problem
where we are given instance
given the lattice as the instance and
the goal in the problem is to decide
whether lambda 1 of l is at most one or
at least gamma
another problem that is studied in our
work is the bdd problem stands for
which stands for boundary distance
decoding 3d problem in lp node with
relative distance alpha is defined to be
the problem where we are given lattice l
and target t
and also we are given the promise that
the target t
is close to less that is the distance of
target t and to the lattice it is at
most alpha times the lambda one of the
lattice
and the goal in the problem is to find
the
closest lattice vector to the target t
in the in the lattice l
here to remark smaller alpha parameter
corresponds to a stronger promise
because we could see that the target is
closer to the lattice and thus it yields
easier problem
here we also have a
figure for
an example of the bdd problem
if we consider the red vector t as a
target then
here in the problem the goal is to find
the closest lattice vector to the red
target
while if the target is outside all the
green circles
the the bd problem does not care about
that case
and
a
pretty standard approach to fine-grained
hardness
is to assume the exponential time
hypothesis
eth in short and the eth and its
stronger version as eth assumes the
exponential
exponential hardness of three set and
k-set problems respectively
in our work we also consider the gap
variance of the of eth and seth where
problems gaps reset and gap case set
are involved instead of
three sets and k sets
um we also use the randomized and
non-uniform variants of all these eth
variants
where randomized on non-uniform time is
is assumed instead of deterministic time
for solving
respective
problems in our work we exploit the
power of all these different eth
variants and
we actually show stronger hardness
results for vdo or sdp under stronger
variants
and in particular to show find great
hardness results we reduce the stat
problem on n variables to latest
problems in rank c times n for some
constant c
this actually follows a line of research
in the
fine fine green hardness of lattice
problems which starts with
the study of closest vector problem
which unfortunately i have no time to
introduce today
and the result extends to
sap bdd and also to another problem
called shortest independent vector
problem
now i'm going to um i'd like to
introduce our results
our first group of results is
are the eth type hardness of bdd problem
the first result says that bdd cannot be
solved
in any sub-exponential time separate
central time for
any
norm p and
any
approximation factor alpha that is at
least 0.98 under non-uniform gap eth
our second result is similarly that bdd
cannot be solved into the level of net
end time for any p and any alpha that is
at least some quantity alpha double
dagger and here we have a have a plot
um
plot of all these quantities we could
see
so here the
dash
is their question
okay so here the
sorry is there a question
i don't think there was a question
okay
uh here the dashed blue line shows the
previous result in db20 and we could see
that our result 2 always improves upon
bp 20 and
our result 1 even improves upon upon
result 2 for small enough p
and importantly including the
euclidean node
our next result is about uh s-e-t-h-type
hardness of bdd
it says that bdd cannot be solved into n
over c time for any p and p that is not
even integer and nac and any alpha that
is at least on the alpha dagger
this is uh this assumes non-uniform gap
as eth
here is the plot comparing our result 3
to the previous
result in bp 20 you could see that our
results 3
improves the previous result when
p is small enough and c is large enough
our last result is a scth type hardness
of sdg problem
it says that for um
so svb problem cannot be solved in to
the n over c time for any p that is
large enough
that is at least about 2.1 and not even
integer
and
for any c that's as at least cp
here to remark cp approaches 1 when p
goes to infinity so this is basically
saying that sap cannot be solved in
integrity and time
for
uh for the l infinity norm
here we have a have a summary of the
all the results about hardness as well
as algorithms for the svd problem
in the previous work as18 we have to
uh to we have similar hardness but only
for the exact version of sbp
our our work here um improves this
result to the uh approximate version of
scp and we also have dmp hardness or sdp
for any constant gamma
and for large constants we have some
concrete exponential time algorithm
for gamma being some large enough
polynomial
we have some improved exponential time
argument and finally when gamma is
exponential we have
the problem is easy to solve
so here due to the limit of time i could
only introduce one
one night a year in the proof that is
called locally dense gadgets roughly
speaking it's
against where we have exponentially more
close than short lattice vectors here in
the picture we can see that around the
target t dagger we have four close
vectors but we if we consider open ball
around the origin there's only it only
contains the origin
and we have a main theorem that
generically turns locally gadgets into
harness results for lightest problems
finally we construct the gadget from
either from the integer lattice or from
a piecing number results by bladders
and we actually get all of our results
by instantiating the main theorem with
these gadgets i'll just briefly mention
the open question first one is
whether we could de-randomize the whole
process
to mark we have randomness in both
constructing the gadgets and also in the
process of the main theorem and second
one is whether we could construct better
gadgets
thanks a lot that's the end of my talk
thank you
any questions
we have time for one minute quick
questions
maybe i can ask so what is the
issue in doing gap amplification
techniques for like using tensoring
lattices to go from oneplus epsilon to
any constant
yeah i guess here um
because we are considering fine grain
hardness we need to re we need to have
reduction
like
with
constant with linear uh block up blow up
in the rank
so i guess
those amplification techniques such as
maybe tensoring
would
have some uh
super linear blow up in the ring
thank you
can we have the
next speaker please because we have to
keep this moving
feel free to contact the speaker
over email
or if we have some time left in the
session in the end
say are you this next speaker
yes i believe so all yours
can you hear me
yep
okay should i start
yeah please start i'll give you uh
on the chat one minute mark before the
last minute
okay um
so do you see the slides i do see the
slides yeah
okay
um
so i'm gonna go with a short talk and
then we can go to questions
uh so
in this work we give a sub-quadratic
time algorithm that approximates
three-edged distance within a constant
factor
all right
uh so here is a you know
examples that example that shows void
treated distance matters in general
so you may be familiar with the edit
distance problem
there you the goal is to
compare two dnas for example you have
two strings
and then you want to know how many
changes you need to make to one of them
to make it equal to the other okay
that's uh generally the notion of
editing
sometimes you want to go further for
example say you have two codes
and you want to know how far the two
codes are from one another
obviously you can represent your code as
a string and do edit distance but then
you would lose some information
so i don't know if you can see my mouse
but
here we have a command which is nested
under the main function so there is a
nestedness between them
when you represent everything as a
string you would lose that
if you want to incorporate that kind of
information in your computation
you would rather you represent your code
as a rooted tree
and then every node of the tree would
become every command would become a node
of the tree and then if there is a
nestedness it like one command becomes a
chart of the other okay
that's
the whole idea and if there's any
questions feel free to ask why don't
give it
okay
um
so let me define the problem formally in
addition we have two
strings and we want to know how many has
been transformed into other
one um these basic operations are
character edition character removal and
character some substitution
sometimes there is weights
but for simplicity we usually assume
that everything has a unit cost
okay so we can solve it with quadratic
time it's a simple dp
so i'll leave that to you as an exercise
and um well
this is not easy to prove but there's a
very very famous work that shows that
this quadratic time algorithm is kind of
the best we can do for at the distance
all right now what about three edit
distance
this time we would have two rooted trees
every node has a label
and then we want to transform the first
rooted tree into the second tree
the base basic operations are inspired
by editor so this time instead of
character we have node addition we can
add a node in the middle of a tree
or remove an existing node or change the
label of one of them
and then we would ask the same question
how many of these operations is
necessary to make a
transformation okay
uh it's harder than edit distance
because of two special cases so if the
um
trees are a star or the trees are a path
in that case the problem is exactly
equivalent to edit the sets but in many
cases the structure is more complicated
so you would expect that
the problem is actually hard
okay um
so
why does it like what's the difference
between these two problems this is a
very good example for that
say you have two codes and you want to
compare them
the first code is a both of the codes
are
on a bunch of nested for
loops the first code always starts with
a block of a and ends with a block of c
or it starts with a block of b and ends
with a block of t
the same we have for the second gold
except that we start with block of a and
end with d or we start with b and end
with c and we alternate between these
formulas
now what is the point the point is that
if you represent these two chords as two
strings
you would think that the edit distance
between them is this
i'll leave that to you as an exercise
but if you rather represent them as two
rooted trees
you can see that there is a big
difference between them so in order to
make a transformation you need to make a
change in every level of the root
entries so actually the creativity sense
is omega object
okay so
the the values would be
far
um what do we know for three edit
distance um there's been a lot of
algorithms
the first one had run time n to the
sixth then it was improved to end before
there's and and you blow again and then
there's enqueue
this is the
um you know the latest result
that gets truly sub-cubic time and it
still solves the problem exactly
i have to note that this only works if
there is no basing with that if there
are some weights involved in the problem
then there are some conditional concepts
better better than cubic is
most likely impossible
also there are some approximate
solutions um
in quadratic time we can get as close
like we can get one plus epsilon
approximation
and here epsilon is
arbitrarily a small constant
and in also near linear term we can get
down to root an approximation
okay now what is the goal the goal is to
get constant approximation in
subquadrative time
and the reason we started with this
question um
is that
this question was opened for edit
distance for quite a long time
you can see how progress is made for
editless sense so in truly subquadratic
time the trivial algorithm
used to lose end to the epsilon
approximation and then over the time
this factor was improved
in recent years we got to constant
approximation
and that's the state of our result for
it
the reason we thought that could be
possible for creative sense is simple
the whole idea of this algorithm that
loses constant is using triangle
inequality
and that also carries over to the
distance so it seems that the ideas can
also work for that problem too
okay so tell you a little bit about the
ideas but if you're interested in the
actual algorithm you can listen to the
uh
long longer version of the term
okay so here is the theorem that gets
constant factor for every distance
are three steps in the algorithm
the one step that they explain to step
one because that is the
main contribution of this word and then
the other two steps we just borrow from
the previous work as they are so we
don't change that
in the first step there is a reduction
at the at the end of that reduction i
show you that there is a matrix we are
looking for and and in the next two
steps uh we find that matrix
okay so i'll just tell you what we can
do for what we're doing step one
our algorithm for three added distance
is the same thing except that as i
told you step one wouldn't work for
three edit distance so we have to come
up with a new step one that also works
for that and that's our actual
contribution so our contribution is a
modified step one that actually works
for threatening systems as well as step
two and three we just borrowed them from
previously
okay so what is step one
step one is a in a kind of a simple
reduction
for edit this sense there are two
strings in the input
we want to know what's the edit distance
between them
in step one we break the strings into
smaller windows
every window is an interval of the
strings and then we prove that all it
takes for us to approximate that answer
is to know the edit distance between
these fingers
okay
so here's an example let's say these are
the two strings
we would make these windows the length
of every window is substantially smaller
than the lengths of the original strings
and they could potentially have overlaps
why do we do that
let's put the windows of the first
string on the left
and the windows of the second string on
the right
we look for this matrix
we want to find the values of this
matrix what are the values the values
tell you the edit distance between pair
of fingers so every row corresponds to
one window of the first string every
column corresponds to one window of the
second string and these values tell you
what the distances are okay that we're
doing step two and three but let me tell
you what what we can do if the matrix is
given to us
okay so suppose the matrix is available
then we can run a simple dp it's
basically the same dp that solves every
distance in
a quadratic time but instead of going
character by character we go
window.window and because of that the
overrun term is so quadratic so i'm
going to be quick because uh there's one
minute remaining
all right so
step two and three find the matrix for
us
so for three distance we're gonna do the
same thing first we turn this the tree
into a string um we put open and closing
parenthesis for every note and
the children of every note the
parentheses corresponding to the
children of every node is included in
the parenthesis of the
parenthood
the window idea wouldn't work here
because if you just go by
with windows every window may only
contain opening or closing parentheses
so we have to come up with a better
structure which we call super window it
has two pieces the left and the right
the left one considers the open it
contains the opening and the right one
contains the closing okay so it would be
the same thing except that instead of
having just windows you would have
windows and super windows again we look
for this matrix
and the elements of this matrix would
tell us the edit distance between
windows and super windows so that matrix
we do in step two and three it's similar
to the way we saw that it descends once
the matrix is given we we can again run
a dp and solve the problem again the
only difference is that instead of
having just windows we have windows and
super windows so the dp gets a little
bit more quality
all right um um so this is the theorem
it's pretty much the same thing
except that it
runs in it it works for three additions
okay
okay thank you so much
any quick questions
i guess
we can move to the next speaker then
thank you again
um
where's the next speaker
how do i how do i pronounce your name
uh so how can you hear me
yes i can hear you uh
yeah
could you please unshare the screen
oh yes
can you unshare the screen
okay i'm trying
it should be at the top
there should be something green okay
thanks thanks
uh so i will send you a message around
when you have one minute left
okay thanks
can you see the slide yes i can thank
you okay great
so uh
yeah so uh
this is a joint work with the uh shine
ahmad
chen malvika raj and ryan williams uh
i'm searching so uh let me start by uh
explaining the two key words in the
title of our paper learning author
protocols and the fine-grained
complexity
so
suppose we have two parties merging an
author an author wants to evaluate some
function but he only has very limited
computational power so he lets merlin to
help him compute the answer of this
function but uh
he wants to wants to prevent merlin from
cheating so he wants berlin to prove to
him that the answer is indeed correct
to do this we have this proof system
where
the proven merlin
sends
author the answer together with a proof
string
and then
after runs a verification procedure
which is randomized
the input here is the input string x the
answer are claimed by berlin and
also the proof string
and uh
we want this product protocol to satisfy
two
requirements
first completeness if the answer is
correct then there should be a proof
string such that the verifier accepts
with probability one
and if the proof sorry if the answer is
incorrect then for any proof uh this
verifier should reject with a
probability at least two-thirds
and we call the merging author time of
this protocol
is the proof length plus the
time complexity of this verification
procedure um
which we run on the word ram machine so
here we mean that we take into account
the time for reading the entire proof
stream
into the verification time okay and we
remark that if we here require that the
rejection probability is one then
this becomes a non-deterministic
algorithm
okay now let's look at fine-grained
complexity so in franklin complexity
there are several central problems that
are conjectured to be difficult to solve
uh such as
orthogonal vectors three sum and the
orbital shortest path
and uh based on these hardness
assumptions we can use fine-grained
reductions to show conditional hardness
for many other problems
and recently there is some interest in
studying the merlin author protocols for
essential problems in fingering
complexity so here is one example
uh the previous work by williams
which studied the orthogonal vectors
problem
so this problem is conjecture to be hard
the best known algorithm
needs roughly quadratic time to solve it
uh but uh williams in 2016 showed that
uh
solving the ov problem and
they can even solve the counting version
which is harder
it can be done in
n times d m a time where d is the
dimension of the input vectors so this
running time is nearly linear in the
input size so it is
near optimal
and
it gives nearly quadratic speed up
compared to the best known quadratic
algorithm and this refuted the merlin
author uh strong eth conjecture
so uh
and um
this result also led to many subsequent
works uh such as brooklyn and caskey's
ma protocols for other problems and also
some
uh works in finding cryptography and
average case finding complexity so in
this work our questions
are there fast burning after protocols
for other problems in fine grained
complexity
and here uh
we show that the answer is yes uh in
this work we showed near optimal burning
author protocols for threesome and
apsp which are
two other central problems
in fingering complexity besides ov and
we also have many additional results
so here
we we can divide our main results into
four groups so let me go through each of
them
so our first uh result is about the k
sum algorithm where we are given n
integers and we want to decide if there
exists
k of them that sum to zero here k is a
fixed integer at least three
and
uh the best known algorithm for
threesome takes a quadratic time and
more generally for k sum the uh best
known running time is k n to the k over
two ceiling
and in this work uh we show that
uh
certifying that a given list of n
integers doesn't have a k sum solution
uh can be done merlin author time n to
the k over three
so in particular we can
certify no three sum in near linear
berlin author time
which is a near optimal
and we can compare our result with the
previous result by carmel sino at all
which gave a
non-deterministic algorithm for the node
3 sum problem in n to the 1.5 time
so our results show that if we use the
power of randomness we can improve this
running time running time from n to the
1.5 to
near linear in n
and our switzerland protocol has many
implications in finding complexity for
example the subsystem problem
that the best known algorithm for this
problem runs in roughly 2 to the n over
q time and we show that no subsystem can
be certified by an mi protocol in 2 to
the n over 3 times and this uh improves
the previous result by netherlands uh
with a slightly uh better than n over
two m a time
and also
uh
our uh fusion protocol can be used to
give a
near linear time mma protocol for the
mean plus convolution problem so this
problem uh is also conjectured to
require and square time um and
we show that it can be done in nearly a
time by and learning other protocol
our second set of results is about
counting clicks so uh so previously
there
was some results on counting k clicks in
a n vertex graph and there's some uh ma
protocols achieving nearly quadratic
speed up and in
this work we consider a harder problem
which is zero weight k click counting
we are given a simple undirected graph
with n vertices and m edges with integer
edge weights we want to count the number
of k clicks in this graph with zero
total weight and our theorem is that
this problem can be solved in m a time
and to the
k over 2 ceiling
and in particular for counting 0 8 4
clicks
we can solve it in
n squared merging after time which is
near optimum for for dense graphs
and we also have some further
improvement for odd k on sparse graphs
for example counting zero-way triangle
can be done in uh near linear array time
in terms of the number of edges
and
using our counting sorry using our zero
weight
triangle uh protocol we can give a near
optimal uh protocol for the rps shortest
path problem
okay uh we can also compare it with the
previous result by carmozino at all
which gave a non-deterministic algorithm
for apsp in end to the 2.94 time
okay our third set of result is about k
onset
so suppose we are given a kcnf
and the best known algorithm for kcnf
set runs in 2 to the m minus a constant
times n over k time for some constant c
and
here we show that
uh certifying that the kcnf is
unsatisfiable can be done in 2 to the n
over 2 minus
some constant times n over k time
and the previously
best known algorithm for k onset problem
runs in two to the n over two time so we
achieved a slight improvement here
okay uh let me speed this
so our fourth uh result is about
quantified boolean formula so it's a
canon canonical key space complete
problem uh and the blue first algorithm
takes two to the end time
the previous work by williams gave a
three-round ama protocol
in two to the two and over three times
and it was asked as a open question
whether we can get uh m a protocol in uh
this uh better than two to the end time
and we show that the answer is yes
uh we we show the uh may protocol in two
to the fourth n over five times for uh
certifying true qbf
okay so these are all our results
and uh
i list two open problems here uh can we
improve the no subset sum protocol from
two to the n over three to two to the n
over four
and can we certify true qbf in two to
the n over two m a time these are two
interesting open questions and thanks
for listening
thank you so much speak thank you
any quick questions we have our 30
seconds
i'll talk in the next speak release
thank you
thank you so much again
the next speaker is
subhashri
yeah
i will uh send you when it's one minute
left on the chat
yes so you see this slicing yeah okay
yes good
oh just to set up
yeah okay hi everyone oh something is
going wrong i don't think it's yeah
i can't see this
oh you don't see any slide okay
[Music]
now do you see something
yes
how useful are content computers
yes oh
yes
okay
for some reason it's going automatically
and it's going really fast and i don't
know what this is maybe you can use the
yeah just this version
yeah okay
okay fine
hi everyone i am subhishi patro and
today i'll be talking about fine grain
complexity via quantum works okay this
is a joint work with
harry bowman bruno loft and florian
spellman
so we would like to know how useful
quantum computers are
and
because quantum computers are a more
powerful model of computation
and um but the problem is
quantum speed up is not guaranteed for
all problems
like for example for problems like
integer factorization and discrete log
we have
exponential quantum speed up but for
problem like uh three sum or triangle
finding the speed up that we know is
only polynomial
and for problems like edit distance
pressure distance we don't even know of
any quantum speed up
and for for problems which are like on
order search like searching over
like a list of and inputs we know that
the quantum speed up is optimal but for
problems like traveling salesman cnfsat
see speed up is not known to be optimal
and for problems like recommendation
algorithms we thought we had an
exponential speed up but turned out that
it is not
and
recently there was this unfortunate
result which also said that if some
problems have only quadratic speed up
then with the current error techniques
we are not going to be
gaining any advantage for practical size
problem
so clearly it's very important for us to
now know which problems we should you
know invest quantum computers for so
actually ryan suggests that you unselect
the used timings on the top
narration boxes and then you should be
able to
so it's
yes okay cool thank you thank you so
much okay yeah so now for example there
was this several computational geometry
problems where quadratic quantum speed
up was shown to be possible this was a
paper by ambinus and larka
and in our paper we using some
techniques like conditional on some cond
conjectures we show that these speedups
are the best that is possible for this
computational geometry problem and uh
for people like who are interested in
you know
building quantum algorithms like you
know implementing these quantum
algorithms on quantum computers then it
is clear that it is not going to be
helpful in the near-term future
so we use this family of techniques
called fine grained complexity and i
should also mention that the fine
grained complexity results in the
quantum setting is not
new to this paper uh it has been
explored by other groups and for other
problems like closest pair and edit
distance problem
so
what is fine grain reduction so imagine
we have this problem a which people have
studied and they know it's really hard
they're not able to improve on this
algorithm for problem a
and now you have another problem b now
you want to comment on the hardness of
problem b based on the information that
you have about proper
and we can do that if we could reduce
this problem a to problem b okay
but how would is that going to help us
so if there was a fast algorithm for
problem b then we can use that to solve
problem a faster
which is not believed to be possible
and hence there is no fast algorithm for
problem b
so
a lower uh believe lower bound for
problem a implies a lower bound for
problem b here okay
and for
uh this paper we take three problem a to
be this three-sum problem okay
now let me just briefly tell you what
threesome problem looks like
we have this n integers it's very simple
all we want to know is whether there
exists a triple of numbers that add up
to zero
so for this example this is easy to see
that there are there's a solution here
now
obviously there's a trivial enqueue
algorithm but we don't like that
and there's a slightly less trivial n
square algorithm but i'm i'm going to
give you a glimpse of this n square log
n time algorithm
but believe me that the sin square
algorithm exists
so we have this input
we make a copy and we make a third copy
and that is sorted the last one is
sorted
now
we can go over all these n square pairs
and check their sum and check if there
are some exist with the negative sign
and the third list okay that would take
us log in time and because there are n
square of them it would take about n
square log in time okay
uh so now the
for the purpose of this talk i'm going
to ignore all these login factors so
uh i'm going to be
dealing with only the exponents and with
the on n
so it was conjectured that threesome
requires n square time on classical
computer
and
like this conjecture helped us get
little more understanding on a lot of
these other problems like computational
geometry zero edge way triangles
sequence problems lining problems and it
kind of gave an explanatory power as to
why people are not able to come up with
these better algorithms
and um so let's like we focus on these
reductions from threesome to this
computational geometry and zeroth wave
triangle form
and the interesting thing that we
noticed were these reductions in the
classical setting go through something
called sorted threesome it's a like oh
it's
it's a variant of uh actually sorting
but you can assume that to be just
sorted sorting sorting the input and
then giving it
to
ask for threesome and then there were
non-trivial reductions that were given
from sorted threesome process
computation geometry and sorted
threesome to the zero into it
and so
this we will discuss is very trivial and
the other one we won't discuss in this
but they were the non-trivial part okay
like the only reason i'm going to
discuss this
like just believe me that is going to be
important for us in the quantum setting
so i have to discuss this now
if someone asked me how fast can i solve
sorted threesome
now imagine um if i if i have this input
to threesome i can of course sort it in
and log in time
and then suppose i had a sub quadratic
algorithm for soliditism then of course
i can get a sub quadratic algorithm for
threesome but which is not believed to
be possible so squatted threesome must
also require n square time
but now things change in the quantum
world
now for this three sum problem we have a
n log n quantum algorithm uh which is
like almost quadratically faster than
the classical one
what you can do is you have this one
copy of this input but you sorted that
takes n log n time
then
over these n square tuple you do a
grover search now for people who are not
familiar with groverset using grover
search we can search for a particular
element in quadratically like in root
and time if the input length is n
so here we have like n square tuples so
we use grover so it will become root n
and times log n because of this binary
search here so now
it's viable to conjecture that
and on the quantum computer threesome
requires end time whereas on the
classical one we know it requires n
square time that is we believe that it
requires n square time
but the problem is all these classical
reductions that we saw existed in the
classical setting
now
they need not go through anymore and we
will look at one example to see how it
feels
okay now let's look at the same
reduction from threesome to sorted
threesome
now here
we don't have a fast like we don't have
a sub linear time algorithm to sort the
input so we are going to use the normal
sorting suppose
then what we get is like the threesome
requires still end time so we don't get
any inclusion as to how hard throttle
threesome is
so the reduction that was actually
trivial in the classical setting
becomes really hard to quantize but
surprisingly what we saw the reduction
after that is easily quantizable because
there is some local property that we
could use and we could make it quantum
really easily
but
we had to deal with this one so
this becomes the interesting part for us
because we gave a non-trivial way to
comment on the hardness of sorted
threesome by using a quantum walk based
reduction
which is
explained in detail in the paper and
also in the
in the long talk
and we also noticed that using this work
based reduction we were not just able to
comment on sorted threesome but a
variety of sorted version like in which
like some sort of orderings on this
input that would have taken end time
classically we could we would come and
we could comment on hardness of that
problems as well
and
consequently we were able to uh
ensure that these reductions
held in the
quantum setting as well and
as a consequence we were able to prove
some tight linear lower bound for most
of these computational geometry problems
and we were able to show that the zero
edge weight triangle finding problem uh
has an endpoint 1.5 algorithm
and which is tight
and
so uh we believe that sorry especially
you have a question on that also
can you wrap it up less than anyone
yes yes should i answer the question
first yes
okay
okay let me then finish i have another
two slides
so uh we believe fine grain reductions
are the promising way forward
for
to prove anything beyond query bounds
that we get uh especially for super
linear lower bounds
and
we also believe the proof strategy that
we gave to prove
the hardness of sorted threesome can be
helpful for us to prove other results uh
based on like you know other orderings
of threesome and other directions from
there onwards
and but one thing to notice here is not
all of these geometry problems are
closed there are some of these geometry
problems whose algorithms
like
we
think
uh
are the best but we don't there's still
a gap and we don't know how to prove it
yet
and future directions are uh there are
other
uh threesome heart problems in the
classical setting that are yet to be
explored in the quantum world
and
like i said there are some open of open
problems here that has to be addressed
and finally there are other problems
like threesome like cnfsat or apsp which
can become central to the you know
hardness
conjecture and
lower bounds can be proved based on
those hardness
thank you for the attention uh
thank you so much thank you
so the question on the chat is what is
the cost of the quantum reduction
between threesome and sorted threesome
now
so so this uh this reduction goes
through this uh walk based thing
so um okay so what we do is we use this
walk algorithm and the walk algorithm
actually
like
makes much smaller instances of these
threesome problem and searches for a
marked element there so if i have to
think like it's not easy for me to right
now think
how costly the quantum reduction would
be because it's
it's like a
uh
it's like breaking the problem into
smaller problems and then
uh checking so let me just just just
give me a second so it'll be there be a
setup cost so that will be about n bar
2
3 no n part 3 by 4
and an update cost
yeah i think it will be about
n by n part three by four if i'm not
wrong but um
i'm i'm not confident here yeah
can we have the next speaker please
thanks again question sure
yeah
i actually
i have another question so what's the
lower bound
upper bound and normal for bounded value
do we know that like if there's an upper
bound of the values of the
elements
like if the upper bound is t we can
solve it in time like t like t
for classic yeah
so i haven't said that in the quantum
setting because the the technique that
we use for classical thing when there's
a bounded
range is fourier transform right fast
fourier transform but in the quantum
setting though there's a fast fourier
transform algorithm but it is not really
the same it doesn't output all these
elements
it just puts it on the amplitude so i
don't know if you can use that
very cleverly
i have to think about this okay can you
also
unshare your stream
oh yes sorry yeah
yes
great side
so i'll again give you one minute thing
although we are running quietly
okay should i start now yeah
uh okay i'll be very quick because a lot
of what i'm going to say was also
covered in the previous start so again
in this work you wanted to also you know
make a connection between quantum
algorithms and fine grain problems
so these are the problems that i care
about
these are simple problems like we teach
them algorithm design edit this snapset
subset some
very easy problems and we know quite a
lot
about them in the classic setting
in quantum we don't know too much
especially there is one question which
is very interesting and that was the
motivation for our work
as this was also discussed in the
previous start
editions and lcs are longest common
subsequence these are kind of like
very famous and important problems in a
fine grain
our classic understanding is kind of
tight we know that they can solve them
in quadratic time and there is a kind of
a matching lower bound
but when it comes to quantum we don't
know too much especially because the
lower bound that we proofread distance
goes through this problem which is
called orthogonal vector
and ov can be solved in linear time
so through this problem there is no way
to prove a quadratic bound quadratic
lower bound
but yet we don't have any better
algorithm the best quantum algorithms
you are aware of
um
are are exactly the same like the best
classic algorithms so we don't know any
improvement
and it's open whether we can improve the
lower bond or upper boundary force
so that was the you know question we
started with
we didn't answer this question but we um
you know we solved this question for
other similar projects
all right
um so again this was something that was
discussed in previously in a fine grain
we try to reduce problems together so we
usually think of a problem as black
verbs and then we
like we think of that algorithm as black
works and try to use it to solve other
problems
in quantum we've go very low levels
sometimes we draw circuits and using
quantum uh physics we improve their
options
okay so um for example in fine grain
these are some conjectures apsp is about
the runtime of you know finding these
senses in a graph set is about
runtime of solving sat and max plus
convolution is about the runtime of
finding the convolution of two sequences
these are the conjectures
based on these conjectures with drivers
for example if edit distance can be
solved faster
with that we can come up with a faster
algorithm for that and that would be
inconsistent with set so that gives us
kind of a lower one for editors
all right in quantum we can actually
improve the runtimes and that makes the
picture very interesting
for example grover's
gives us a faster algorithm for another
let's say we have a sequence of size and
you're looking for one element in that
sequence
classically we have to go over all of
the elements so it takes linear time but
roberts can do that for us in
time router
the other problem is element is
thickness this time you're given two
sequences of size n you want to know if
there is one element which is shared
between them
again for obvious reasons you need omega
of time in the omega of end time in the
classic setting but in quantum you can
improve that to end to it
and the same holds for pattern matching
this time you have a text and a pattern
um you want to know if the pattern
appears in the text obviously you need
to read the text on the pattern so it
takes
linear time to solve it basically but
quantum improves that to root time
and you may
notice that all of onion quantum even
though the inputs are linear that's
because we assume there is an oracle
that gives us the elements of it
okay
so what do we want to do we want to
bridge the gap so we want to do the same
taking we want to use the same
techniques that we're using for
ingredient
but instead of starting from the
existing classic algorithms we would
like to start from the existing quantum
algorithms and that gives us better
quantum algorithms for the recipient
okay
these are the two problems that we
consider
one of them is called longest palindrome
substring
the other one is called longest common
substring
so in lps
you have a sequence of size
m
you want to find an interval which reads
the same both forward and backwards
we call that pattern
and among such intervals you want to
find the one which is largest
the second problem is longest common
substring uh we refer to it as as lcs
but there is also another lcs problem
which is called longest common
subsequence
in subsequence elements have to be like
don't have to be close to each other
there could be gaps between them but in
substring all the elements of the
solution have to be next to each other
so in longest common substring we have
two sequences of size n
we want to find a substring
which is the same in goes up
all right
um so why these two problems is because
they're kind of equivalent in the
classic set um
we can solve both of them in linear time
it's basically with the same algorithm
uh so all we need to do is to read the
strings
we make a suffix through out of the
strings
and then if we find one node of the
suffix gives us a solution for lcs if we
find another node it gives us a solution
for that so roughly they are the same we
just need to change one line after code
to switch between the two problems
uh our
the message of our work is that even
though the problems are equivalent in
the classic setting they're not
equivalent to quad
what's not surprising is that we can
solve both of them in sub-linear time
so our solution for lps takes time
routine
and our solution for lcs takes time n to
the 5 6.
what is surprising about this work is
that
there is a gap between the runtimes we
show lower bound for lps which is root
10 which is tied
but the lower bound for lcs is n to the
two thirds
and i want to emphasize that the lower
bond is unconditional meaning that no
matter what you definitely need time
entry to set to solve fcs which is kind
of surprising because lps can be solved
so even though they're equivalent to the
classic setting the quantum setting
they're different
okay um so i'm not planning on
explaining the algorithms to you i just
want to wrap up by telling you that
after the publisher work
there's another work that improves the
result
their runtime for lcs is tight so they
they also get end to the truth
so their runtime is tied up to party dog
fighters
and i guess there are a lot of other
problems that are
that have the same situation the classic
setting like apsp center uh diameter
these are kind of problems that are
equivalent
but i suspect that when it comes to
quantum we can show some gap so these
are kind of interesting problems to
study for future
okay so if there's any questions again
answer
thank you very much
any quick questions before we wrap up
this session
uh
let me ask a quick question then
what what is the intuition that there is
this gap between the two problems
um
for for the
like quantum world yeah in the quantum
world how come
up is there any quick conclusion that
people yeah so
for example uh negative like finding a
negative triangle
that can be done easily with
uh grover's algorithm if you're looking
for three edges that you know the
summation of these numbers is less than
zero classically we have to go over all
of the edges but grover's algorithm can
do that much faster for us so there
seems to be a faster algorithm for that
problem but for example almost show this
path
and that's very difficult to
improve the runtime
even though these two problems are
equivalent in the classic setting it
seems that in the quantum setting
there's a gap between them
makes sense i see it's also the witness
size probably smaller and one
any other questions
it's not and we're also over time
so thank you to all the speakers and
everyone
you